hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast NGS and clinical research
presented by Jennifer frost L we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kyochon as the innovative
market and technology leaders hydrogen
creates sample to incite technologies
that enable access to valuable molecular
insights from any biological sample the
mission is to make improvements in life
possible by enabling our customers to
which gave outstanding success and
breakthroughs in life sciences applied
testing Pharma and molecular diagnostics
to learn more about kyochon please visit
www s I am Brenda Kelly Kim elaborate
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located on the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right finally if you have any
trouble hearing or seeing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window to let us know or
you can use the Q&A button and we'll try
to resolve your problem this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the get your free CEO CME
credits button at the bottom left corner
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
select the CAC Emmy button under your
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate I'd now like
to introduce our presenter Jennifer
Fausto jennifer has her masters and
molecular and cell biology University of
California at Berkeley she did her
graduate research and dr. Susan Marcus's
lab where she analyzed the deep
properties of proteins from thermophilic
and Lisa Phillip microbial species she
has worked in next-gen
sequencing for the last seven years
including management of clinical next
generation sequencing projects for the
Broad Institute of MIT and Harvard as
well as NGS biomarker assay development
for takeda pharmaceuticals oncology
translational medicine today at kyochon
jennifer is a senior global product
manager covering a portfolio of
universal workflow ngf library
preparation products please join me in
welcoming jennifer and I now turn the
presentation over to / all right thanks
Brenda so hello my name is Jennifer
foxtel and i'm a senior global product
manager for kyochon NGS life sciences
group and I'd like to thank everyone on
the call for joining us for this webinar
today so I currently work in the
development as new next-generation
sequencing wet lab products cryogen and
adventure eos has become more common in
the clinical environment i found i
frequently run into clinicians and
clinical researchers at events such as
this one who are interested in what in
exploring new techniques for their
research but aren't quite sure exactly
what makes next-generation sequencing a
different type of test from standards
than Sanger sequencing or how validation
clinical validation of an NGS SI might
be similar or different from other
commonly used biomarker discovery
techniques such as IHC or qpcr and yet
every year there's sort of an increasing
number of next-generation sequencing
based assays that are validated and
enter into clinical practice or are
developed for preclinical research
purposes you know NGS you is being used
in the clinic today include
pre-implantation genetic screening
liquid biopsy detection of tumor
mutational profiles as sequence driven
chemotherapy decisions as well as
determination of biomarkers for response
to a particular drug or treatment
measurements so shown here on the slide
I've included just a few examples of
ways in which next-generation sequencing
is starting to become
common practice in a clinical
environment so on the far left is a very
recent Newsweek article I think from
just a month or two ago the described
waves in which researchers at Children's
Mercy Hospital in Missouri along with
adecco genome is a company in California
they've worked together to address one
of the major challenges associated with
implementing NGS in the clinic and I was
a historically much longer turnaround
time than typical clinical diagnostic
tests from the time that a sample is ja
collected from the patient for the time
that that result can be returned to the
physician to influence patient care in
the center is a paper from industry test
provider foundation medicine this paper
basically describes how they went about
developing and validating a clinical
grade NGS test specifically for the
oncology market and then on the far
right right is an investigator paper
publishes by researchers at the
dana-farber cancer institute in which
human holds exome sequencing along with
computational clinical interpretation
was used to actually guide patients
precision cancer care in real time and
so to start off this presentation and
start to talk about you know how
researchers get started doing this type
of work or you know what is really meant
by next-generation sequencing I'll go
through a few basic agenda items so
first I'll set the stage for providing
some background on exactly what is meant
by and next-generation sequencing
technology and additionally I'll walk
through some main types of NGS essays
and provide some discussion on why a
particular type of assay might be a good
fit for a study or not next we'll talk
about some of the key questions that a
researcher may want to explore when
deciding you know what to implement an
NJ sfa in clinical studies for the first
time and finally I'll try to get into a
few specifics about how to validate an
inch es ese for use in a clinical
environment and the example that I'll
use is ample con panel based targeted
resequencing
this is a relatively common NGSS a type
for clinical use and I'll kind of use
that example to talk about some of the
clear guidelines that can be followed
when implementing an ng FSA as well as
kind of go through some hypothetical
data of what validation experiments and
validation data for an amplicon panel
type approach might look like some
things that I am NOT going to include in
today's talk number one there is a ton
of change in progress going on in the
regulatory environment for critical NGS
but I am NOT a regulatory expert and so
I will leave this to other speakers at
this event to fill in details about the
current thinking in the current movement
from FDA as well as some of the other
clinical advisory groups looking at next
generation sequencing second one of the
major challenges for implementing NGS in
the clinic continues to be the design
implementation and standardization of
bioinformatics pipelines to analyze the
massive quantity of data that is
produced this could fill an entire talk
on its own and so I'll kind of leave
this as an exercise for another talk or
another time to go through some of the
basic ways that NGS data can be analyzed
and then finally the last topic that is
very interesting but I think doesn't fit
in today is reporting standards for
clinical NGS data so at the end of the
day what we're looking for in a clinical
test environment is there's actionable
test results that a physician can use or
that a clinical study can use to draw
conclusions from the data they're
produced there's still a lot of debate
in the field a lot of different ideas
about how to do reporting for clinical
NGS and again I'll leave that for a
different talk all right so getting into
an introduction to next-generation
sequencing so let's make something or
make what makes the sequencing method
grouped into this category of next
generation or next generation sequencing
so NGS comprises a collection of
relatively new technologies or new
techniques that have really been
commercialized in the last decade or so
to allow rapid
sequencing of large portions of an
individual's DNA or RNA or even their
entire genome and this has been made
possible largely by techniques that
allowed a rapid decrease in the cost per
base of the individuals beacon
sequencing reaction largely through
miniaturization of the assay auto vision
of the chemistry and automation of the
analysis or base calling portions of the
workflow and so to kind of illustrate
this I like to show it as two basic
technology jumps that many people
listening to this webinar may be
familiar with so the first is you know I
don't know how many people listening
have ever run a sequencing slab shell I
personally have run just one I would not
do it again so this is the way that
sequencing was done and in a basic
research environment and so probably you
know 15 10 to 15 years ago and so the
idea is basically that with this huge
slab gel-based the apparatus using
radioactive nucleotides to produce
banding on a autoradiogram you could run
just a few samples per gel on up to
about a 300 base pair max read lengths
if that's the quality of data was really
good and base calling was actually done
visually by looking at the pattern of
the different bands on the gel and so
the throughput of doing this like if you
can imagine trying to sequence the whole
genome using these gels it would really
take you forever and would be extremely
tedious and there was no good way to
automate it so that first major
technological jump was the switch from
gels to sequencing using capillary
electrophoresis and so now instead of
separating samples by running different
lanes on the job the samples were
actually separated into their own
individual very fine glass capillaries
and so what this did was it allowed a
higher number of samples per run between
eight and 384 depending on the version
of the technology longer reads because
that fin capillary had better resolution
and also instrumentation was developed
to facilitate automated loading and
automated base calling
those sequencing reactions so the next
jump then from capillary to
next-generation sequencing follows that
same pattern so what we're going to do
again is miniaturize that sequencing
reaction even further so instead of a
small bundle of capillary tubes that you
can hold in your hand we're actually
transitioning to a microscopic 2d array
on a surface but the same idea right so
we have individual sequencing reactions
now instead of each one having their own
capillary those sequencing reactions are
bound to a solid surface and separated
in 2d space from each other and so this
allowed us to jump from you know
hundreds of samples or dozens or
hundreds of samples from capillary to
even the 2007 original celexa sequencer
which could sequence 40 million
simultaneous sequencing reactions on a
glass flow cell about the size of a
microscope slide and so the key here is
to separate those sequencing reactions
in physical 2d space there have been a
couple of different strategies for doing
this the top picture on the right there
is of the original 454 technology in
which DNA is amplified on tiny beads and
then those beads are settled into into
Wells on the surface that keep them
separated from each other and so they
can be imaged and then on the selector
flow cell at the bottom there's actually
a lawn of primers coating that glass
surface and the samples are covalently
bound to those primers allowing them to
stay put and stay in one place so that
they can be imaged through the course of
a sequencing reaction and again the the
point of all these technologies is that
by making the sequencing reactions
smaller and being able to run a larger
number of simultaneous reactions or
people will say massively multiplex this
caused a massive drop in the amount of
in the cost to sequence a given total
whole genome and by reducing the cost
per base we've actually been able to
expand the number of types of studies
the number of types
questions that were economically
feasible for researchers to address okay
and so then the next slide I just like
to show a few of the different
next-generation sequencing technologies
that have launched over the last 10
years starting with 454 which is a
pyrosequencing based technology in the
mid-2000s Gila coast which was one of
the first single molecule sequencers the
celexa or alumina based technology in
the late 2000s it was a sequencing-based
synthesis technology still used in the
high seat in my seat instruments today
solid which was a next-generation
sequencing by allegation technology
Pacific Biosciences which is a little
bit of a different technology it's a
long read long read chemistry sorry
where the sequencing is done by
individual polymerase molecules held in
a tiny well with a single molecule of
DNA circulating through that polymerase
the Ion Torrent instruments at the top
there these are instead of taking
pictures of the sequencing reaction and
relying on fluorescent nucleotides like
the illuminant instruments the is our
instruments actually detect the hydrogen
hydrogen ion that is released through
incorporation of a nucleotide to the
sample DNA and then just recently at amp
last week Kuragin also announced the
latest NGS instrument which is the gene
reader and GF system and again this is
this is sort of an amplicon based on
sequencing technology that is combined
with end-to-end support so that the
instrument includes your sample prep
your sequencing as well as the analysis
steps of the workflow okay so i wanted
to next talk about some of the different
types of NGS assayed types because when
getting into utilizing NGS in a clinical
study or in clinical care there are a
lot of questions about what assay would
be most appropriate for the question is
being asked so NGS essays are unique
among many testing methodologies in the
sheer amount of data that can be
generated and the lack of in
definition or hypothesis of what will be
examined also the number of clinical
interpretations that can be made from a
single sample this is really one of the
prime benefit of doing NGS for clinical
studies you just from from the same
sample that could be collected from the
patient you're able to run thousands
even millions of genetic tests
simultaneously and any one of those
tests could be the one that has utility
to diagnose or predict an individual's
risk of disease okay so just to walk
through this slide and explain what
we're looking at so on the left whole
genome sequencing it's sort of the
largest region of interest after that
you can do this essentially involves no
selection of particular regions of the
genome or particular genes of interest
this involves your shotgun sequencing of
all genomic material present the patient
sample whole exome is the next one over
from that reasons to do whole exome so
essentially people will do this because
if it still allows you to cover all of
the protein-coding regions of the genome
but in comparison sort of the the three
gigabytes human whole genome and Exum
covers about 40 mega bases so if you can
imagine if you have a limited or
restricted budget you're going to be
able to do a lot more human whole exomes
for the same amount of money that you
would be able to do whole genome in the
middle there is pcr-amplified based
sequencing this is very popular approach
and in part because it allows you to be
very selective about the regions of the
genome that you are querying through
your test so in amplicon based
sequencing you have carefully designed
primer pairs that will amplify up for
sequencing only the genes or the
portions of the genome that you're
interested in and this you can design a
very small vision of interest that again
allows you to sequence a larger number
of samples for your study or compare a
larger number of patients with the same
diagnosis then you could if you are
looking at a larger region of interest
path now some other options on the right
and I won't talk about too much in this
talk include transcriptome
sequencing or RNA seek again extremely
powerful method using the RNAs direct
from a tissue sample which in addition
to do sort of variant calling and
mutation identification RNA seat can
allow you to look at gene expression on
gene fusions or structural
rearrangements as well as splice
variants that you would only be able to
tell from sequencing RNA and so that the
teacher is really to look at the region
of interest that your essay is going to
explore so larger the region of interest
the greater your data storage and
analysis costs will be but the more
general your essay is if you have
multiple clinical trials or you expect
to be sequencing patients enrolled over
a long period of time having a more
general study or FA design will allow
you to combine those patients together
and actually analyze them as a set for
greater statistical power on the other
side the smaller targeted panels are
easier and less expensive to to run for
a given project but if you have sort of
five different clinical studies running
and each of them is running a unique and
non overlapping set of amplicon targets
it's going to be much harder for you to
combine those data sets together and
actually analyze them at a larger scale
okay and that's just system I
systematize a--'s those applications
again and shows kind of the idea is
basically that entire that should say
frozen samples and frozen tissue and
ffpe based tissue you know sort of a the
highest number of genes or the highest
coverage of the genome would be whole
genome sequencing a typical depth of
affordable sequencing for wgs would be
maybe 10 to 60 X coverage that means
each base in the whole genome would be
covered by the sequencing reaction at
least 10 and up to about 60 times for
accuracy in the middle you have kind of
your exome or RNA seek and for exome a
typical coverage is often about 100 x
and then there at the bottom you have
custom amplicon panels or custom capture
panels and because of the small region
of intro of intra
you're able to drive the sequencing
depth to a much higher level potentially
a thousand X or more and so particularly
oncology researchers tend to like doing
this because let's say that your variant
of interest is present in a very small
fraction of your tumor sample or biopsy
you're going to be able you have greater
sensitivity to detect that with the
higher depth coverage at an amplicon or
exome level as compared to a whole
genome level and again the NGS advantage
for clinical research for all of these
applications is that from the same
samples previously may have been
submitted for just a few qpcr tests
you're now able to obtain diverse
genomic information okay so let's assume
that you have a clinical study coming up
and you're interested in running Angie
sfa I wanted to include a few practical
considerations for some of the next
kinds of things you may want to think
about in moving forward with your
testing plans so first of all NGS
workflows generally require a library
prep step and so what do I mean by
library paps so you collect your sample
you extract nucleic acids in this case
we'll use DNA as an example and so right
there in the middle you can see there's
sort of a cartoon representation of
double-stranded sample DNA and for both
short read technologies this would
additionally be fragmented to
approximately 200 to 600 base pairs to
be compatible with the surface binding
chemistry of either ion torrent or
alumina base chemistry and so the next
step is to add is to add adapters and
it's once those platform-specific
adapters are added that it's considered
an NGS library for Illumina and I on for
it that is generally a linear design so
known sequence adapters are ligated on
to the end and pacbio because they have
more of a continuous or circular loop of
DNA going through the polymerase they
actually added actors in the form of
what they call the smart bell so it's
just a little hairpin loop that goes on
the end on the otherwise functions
similarly to the illuminant
torrent adapters and so one of the
things to consider is how much a DNA is
required for NGS library prep and how
does that compare to the amount of DNA
that you can get from the sample type
available from your study so
historically standard NGS library prep
input has required has been about 100
nanograms to a thousand nanograms
alright so about a tenth of a microgram
up to one microgram and that is very
easy to get from a human blood sample
200 microliters of blood will generally
give you in between five and six and
micrograms of DNA but for other sample
types for example single cells bacterial
cells these circulating DNA isolated
from blood plasma getting up to 100
nanograms can be really really difficult
and so there's been continuous drive to
reduce the amount of DNA required for
NGS library prep and sort of enable some
of these additional applications right
now there are certainly library prep
chemistry's that can get down into the
one nanogram range which is practical
for as i mentioned CF DNA isolated from
plasma and then getting even lower than
that in a single cell sequencing from
both mammalian and bacterial cells is
also possible through whole genome
amplification technologies such as
molecular displacement and location the
next thing to think about when assessing
the sample type available for a study is
how much DNA you be able to get reliably
from your sample type and whether that
is enough for the question that you want
to ask and this is particularly
important for heterogeneous samples such
as tumors or you actually have may have
many different subclones present the
tumor that each have different variants
or different mutational profiles that
you want to analyze so some quick math
that it's helpful to do just a sanity
check the study design is how much
genomic diversity are you going to have
in the amount of DNA that you can
reliably extract from your samples so
assuming that and again we're going to
use a CF DNA example for this just
the map that you dear but assuming that
there are about six pika grams of DNA
for human cells and that all parts of
the genome are equally likely to be
represented in DNA extracted from your
sample and for CF PNAU assume that the
DNA isolated from plasma is actually
mostly derived from the tumor so between
80 and 100 percent tumors arrived just
because tumor cells are slightly less or
slightly more likely to shed DNA then
standard you know lining of your your
blood vessels or other cell types so
especially that means that you have a
fixed amount of genomic diversity
presence in the number of peace grams or
nanograms of DNA that you can isolate
from a sample and so you can see that
your if you've just isolated
approximately one nanogram of GNA your
theoretical maximum unique sequence
steps all right so sequencing depth
derived from unique molecules of DNA
present in your sample is about 350 x
and so unfortunately that is a very
reasonable level so many successfully
extracted cell-free DNA samples for 5 to
10 mils the plasma can definitely get
into the 10 to 100 nanogram range and if
you're lucky enough to be sequencing
from human whole blood or frozen tissue
sample or even sufficient slides of ffpe
again you're going to have no problem
sort of hitting that range another thing
to take a look at however is that that
350 x is sort of a best-case scenario
and in reality is that DNA that you're
able to extract from a sample does not
all make it onto the NGS flow cell and
for conversion into data and so this is
just a sample loss calculation using for
example the alumina truth seek custom
amplicon protocol this is a very common
amplicon based targeted resequencing
protocol but it's a quite a long
protocol and involves a lot of different
steps and as a result there's
considerable sample complexity loss
through each of those processing steps
you can see here that just through basic
molecular biology
um you know binding to the filters doing
pcr binding 2 amperes fri beads for
buffer exchange to make sure the sample
and finally loading it on to the flow
cell what you end up with is really a
very small fraction of even the input
DNA that began the NGS library prep
process and so assuming that now we've
only got about point2 nanograms with DNA
from our original hundreds that are
going to make it onto that flow cell to
generate data our real world maximum
unique sequencing depth drops rapidly
from about 350 x to about 70 X so that's
still plenty for many applications
obviously for any kind of Mendelian
sequencing applications you're going to
be looking at Mendelian homozygous and
heterozygous variances there's no issues
with trying to call those bearing at
summit 70 X threshold but for tumor
sequencing it's important to try and
preserve the genomic complexity of the
sample as best as you can through the
selection of your library prep process
and the elimination of any of those
processing steps that aren't truly
necessary to the next challenge for
establishing NGS in the clinical
environment is following through the
clinical guidelines specifically for
doing testing in a clinical environment
in the last two years guidelines for the
standardization of clinical NGS assays
have started to emerge including an NGS
checklist from the College of American
Pathologists the standardization of
clinical testing workgroup the american
college of medical geneticists
guidelines for NGS and the clinical
laboratory standards Institute's
guidance on best practices to the
development of clinical grade NGS in
addition there's been the approval of 25
10k approved NGS instruments by the FDA
and this has provided some of the first
insights into how the FDA's use NGS
based tests as well as the growing
expectations that ngf assays for
clinical use should be standardized and
validated just like any other clinical
assay
and so it's historically facilities and
providers who have strong expertise and
ngf have not been clinical laboratories
there are that brings up some questions
about how do we merge the necessary
technical know health for these
technologies with an understanding of
the regulatory environment and how to
operate under clinical grade quality
system so that brings up the next big
question which is you know you decided
to incorporate NGS into a clinical study
you've identified the application that
would be the best fit your sort of aware
of clinical guidelines for validation so
the next step is you try to do this
within your organization or do you
outsource and look to a service provider
or a testing lab that is outside and
experience in running NGS so some
reasons to insource you have access to
significantly lower turnaround times so
if you have a study where it's really
important to get data back so that they
can influence patient care in a more or
less real-time basis you know shipping
samples a long distance to a third-party
provider allowing them time to run their
ass a prepared deliverables get them
back to you is generally going to be
longer and so the more of the process
that you can do within your own
controller within your own organization
tends to bring down that turnaround time
when insourcing or using your own
clinical lab it's also much easier to
link the NGS data with the clinical
outcomes information that allows that
data to be interpreted you also
obviously have full control of
laboratory process which can make the
publication process much easier and as
we mentioned a reduced number of wet lab
handling steps so you don't need to
transfer sample into a fresh tube to
send off for the testing lab and fewer
to see steps I mean you're probably
going to QC the sample before it leaves
your facility the service provider is
going to QC the sample again when it
arrives starting to eliminate some of
those steps will leave more DNA or RNA
available for the FA but obviously
common challenges trying to run ng SFA's
in-house does require significant
investment in expertise trained staff
equipment and compliant process
development on the other side reasons to
outsource the assay so being able to
access the the cost and benefit to the
facility that do NGS regularly end its
scale this is a big one and difficult
for labs that are just going to do a
small amount of NGS testing to replicate
higher throughput labs are also more
likely to offer automated processes that
have higher assay reproducibility makes
interpretation of the data significantly
easier and it is often easier to select
a qualified vendor than to physically
build all of that infrastructure
yourself underhand common challenges as
i mentioned vendors who are experienced
in both clinical trials and NGS are
quite limited and so this means that
there can be significant coordination
and education in both directions
required by the investigator or study
sponsor this is just to give up a
picture of you know some of the
organizational complexity but can can
become the reality for setting up some
of these assays especially in the
context of clinical trials so imagine
you have your study sponsor usually
contracting with CRO or a central lab
running this study you have your
clinical sites where the patient samples
are actually being collected or the
blood drives are happening maybe you
have an NGS vendor you're contracting
with to do the wet lab work but in now
suspender who will actually be then
processing those data and turning it
into an interpretable understandable
conclusion and so this all can create
quite long processes that take a lot of
time and require a lot of project
management and coordination and so it's
kind of it's good to be aware of this
potential complexity before getting
started on so you can make good
decisions about how much to do in house
how much to send out and potentially
whether you will need you know staff on
hand to manage some of the transfers
between organisations
so here I include some sample questions
you know if you decide to evaluate NGS
vendors and you want to kind of get a
sense for how they stack up against each
other and which one you may want to work
with in the future so number one by far
is the quality of the data they produce
so not all data NGS data is created
equal you're going to want to be very
clear on what kinds of reports and
they're able to provide you with are
there in process reports or just a
report at the end what kind of data
quality metrics will you receive you
know what are their data quality
guarantees and what happens if the data
they produce do not meet those
guarantees as well as how they're
validating their assets that they can
guarantee to you that the data quality
metrics that you're being provided with
were established in a validated way
project experience is a huge one so do
the vendor that you're exploring have
previous experience with projects of a
comparable scope have they worked with
your sample type before and are they
experts in your sequencing essay or they
only really specialize in one type of
essay and then finally what are their
sample requirements you know in order to
do an amplicon based test or human whole
genome sequencing for example how much
sample is required how much DNA how much
RNA if it's tissue how much tissue do
they require technology available
there's a lot of different kinds of
equipment and laboratory materials that
are needed to run some of these tests so
if you don't want to kind of partner
with a vendor and build up that process
from scratch it helps to make sure that
all that equipment and technology is
available and pre validated before your
study begins as they transfer experience
is also one so if you plan to develop an
essay in your own lab and then transfer
it over to and ngf service provider you
know how much experience is that vendor
have with taking in and externally
developed a PHA and implementing it in
their lab bioinformatics capabilities so
don't be afraid to work with separate
wet lab and analysis vendors it's
relatively rare for revenge
to be good at both what turnaround time
can be can they guarantee or offer for
your project and what kind of
deliverables are you going to get in
that time frame what quality processes
are in place and particularly if you
plan to you know use use your ear NGS
essays for treating patients for
standard of care or for you know
anything beyond exploratory endpoint for
a clinical trial you're going to make
sure that the facility is Clea or cap
accredited at least in the US and then
finally one that I like to put in that
maybe doesn't always make it to list is
there the facilities customer service
and responsiveness NGS essays are still
relatively expensive and require a large
commitment of very precious samples that
are difficult to obtain do you want to
make sure that you are able to get the
information and the feedback from the
vendor you select in a timely fashion
another thing to watch out for is to
make sure that the vendor is extremely
comfortable with the key parameters for
validating a clinical assay and so these
are sort of the quia guidelines standard
accuracy specificity precision
reportable range sensitivity and
reference range if you're going to make
sure that either your internal clinical
lab or an external provider is very
comfortable interpreting these
parameters in the context of an NJ sfa
so for example just to talk about so
accuracy they should have parameters for
filtering out low quality data they
should have standards where they will
not return test results unless there is
adequate sequence depth and uniformity
of coverage to support the variant calls
that they are making this you have a
procedure for confirming any clinically
actionable variants through an
ornithologist techniques either Sanger
sequencing or qpcr or something else for
reportable range this one is interesting
so reportable range for NGS one way that
I like to look at it is this is the
region of the genome that the test is
capable of testing so or is people of
querying so for example
if you have an amplicon sequencing
design where you're really just looking
at a small number of genes or a small
number of genomic regions you're going
to want to see that all of those regions
have been validated and the test is
capable of delivering high quality
sufficient depth data for all of those
regions and if not you know there are
difficult parts of the genome repeat
regions certain alleles that just don't
amplify well you know those should
really be eliminated from the reportable
range for the test sensitivity so this
is particularly important in the context
of oncology sequencing so what is the
lowest fraction of the sample that could
contain an oncogenic variant of interest
that the SI would still be able to
detect and then finally a reference
range so ideally we would have a
reference range with all the possible
outcomes from a clinical tests but
currently we are not to the point where
the human reference genome includes
every possible variant from every
possible person who could be studied and
so this doesn't really exist your NGS
today in the future we hope that there
will be population specific or disease
specific references that will serve as a
more complete reference for clinical in
GF but for the time being reference
ranges is one area in which NGS essays
probably will continue to be a little
bit different from many other clinical
tests okay so for the last part of the
talk I'd like to go through just a few
examples of what a real world clinica
laughs a validation might look like
specifically for an amplicon targeted
receivin singh panel and just give you
an idea of some of the experiments that
might be done the designs of some of the
experiments and what some of those data
might look like okay so here is a
hypothetical a site design and this will
be a amplicon based panel with a
thousand amplicons covering 50 unique
genes and a total region of interest of
about 100 kb so this is relatively small
again I mentioned that fish human whole
exome is about 40 mega bases
this amplicon design is really a much
very very small fraction of the total
exome or whole genome type sequence our
amplicons will be about 160 base pairs
because we plan to use it with a
cell-free plasma-derived DNA sample and
cell-free DNA tends to be relatively
fragmented about 200 base pairs to start
we wanted to make sure that our amplicon
length was slightly smaller than that
we're isolating our DNA using the
cottage and circulating nucleic acids
kit our library prep i have just put in
here the cottage in one step amplicon
library prep kit this will be a new
product coming out in december will be
specific for amplicon sequencing so it
fits well in this workflow and then for
the sequencer we're going to choose an
aluminium I speak for this experiment at
two by a hundred and fifty base pair of
sequencing and the next thing we're
doing is just checking on the sequencing
depths that we can generate so assuming
that our my sacrum can yield us about
five Giga bases of sequence and if we
don't divide that out across 100 kb of
region of interest as well as 96
multiplex samples together / flow cell
it means we're targeting about 500 x
meeting target depth and there at the
bottom i just have a quick diagram to
show the difference between how this
experiment would look if it were a
hybrid capture targeted resequencing
experiment versus an amplicon based
targeting receipt wincing experiment so
imagine that these lines are sequencing
reads that are being aligned to the
human reference genome across the top
you can see that the hybrid capture data
tends to be more staggered those reads
have random start and stop points
whereas the amplicon data your reads
will be neatly defined by the primers in
your amplicon panel design and so there
are some frozen some cons to this but it
can make the analysis of data a little
bit more straightforward just because
you know exactly which region you're
trying to amplify with each of your
primer pairs okay some of the
experiments that we would run to
validate this this application
panel includes looking at the accuracy
and specificity so we have multiple cell
lines with known cosmic mutations
preferably pre-verified be a Sanger
sequencing or qpcr and these can be
basically we can run our panel using DNA
extracted from the cell lines and make
sure that we are detecting all of the
variants that we expect to see from
those sample types reportable range I
mentioned you know we need to look at
okay let's assume that we're going to
have samples with a DNA input between
about 25 nanograms and 150 nanograms so
at those levels of input are we able to
get sufficient sequencing depth for all
of the amplicons in our panel design so
sensitivity or limit of detection this
is in oncology based assays so we want
to do a titration basically of cell line
DNA with a variant of interest in two
variant free wild-type DNA and by
titrating it down between 100 and you
know five or two or one percent we're
able to actually see how low the assay
can go and still detect that variant and
then finally we always want to assess
athlete's performance using a realistic
sample type so since our clinical
samples will not be so line DNA we want
to make sure to qualify the panel using
real-world yes DNA samples as well
alright so one of the first things that
we want to take a look at is our ability
to generate high-quality sequence data
that meets the manufacturer's
specifications so we never want to be
trying to interpret clinical NGS data
that doesn't match the specifications
that the NGS manufacturer says your
platform is capable of generating and so
here we have a titration of different
input amounts and samples run in
duplicate and we want to make sure that
we're seeing very high quality sequence
that's shown in the percent greater than
Q 30 column so we like to see that @ %
greater than Q 30 in at least 80 or 85
percent
and all of these are nicely above that
and that excuse me in the column next to
that we have the percent match you know
there are typically things like
contaminating DNA or sequence reads
derived from the adapter sequence and
those are not going to map to the human
reference because they're not human
sequences so we also like to see that
the percent match stays nice and high
that our process is working well and
that the sequence that we're generating
really is mappable human DNA sequence
another example of some validation data
this is again taking a look at the
reportable range this is actually
separating out the data that we've
generated by the the gene or the
amplicon or the target region so in this
example they're all different genes and
so even though we drive the whole
experiment to an average of 400 or 500 x
steps the actual coverage for each gene
including and included in that panel may
be slightly different and this may be
because that that allele is a little bit
more difficult for a polymerase to
amplify the design of the primers for
that gene may have been more challenging
and so what we do is we kind of break it
down and make sure that there aren't any
genes that the panel is having
reproducible trouble generating coverage
for and so in this this panel you can
see there's kind of one high outlier a
whole bunch of genes that are coming up
with sort of an average or middle
frequent steps and there's just a couple
of genes there at the bottom that the
panel is having a lot of trouble with
and so for a clinical assay it would be
very unlikely that you would be able to
get the kind of sequence steps that
you're looking for for interpreta
Bulgaria from Eugene the recommendation
was even to remove these from the assay
reportable range on the right hand side
reproducibility of target coverage again
just taking a look at the range of the
nucleic acid inputs to the essay and
making sure that you are seeing
approximately equivalent performance for
each gene of interest across that range
another potential experiment is looking
at the reproducibility of somatic allele
frequencies so again we're sequencing if
we're sequencing cell line DNA we would
expect to be able to call a homozygous
variant at close to 1 point 0 frequency
in amongst the sequence reads whereas a
heterozygous variant you'd want to see
approximately fifty percent of the reads
supporting that variant calls across all
of your samples and across all of your
potential input ranges and we see that
nicely here another key experiment to do
particularly for oncology is that sa
sensitivity or limit of detection one
common way of determining the limit of
detection is just to do a mixture
experiment where you have fell line DNA
with some known mutation of interest and
you actually mix that in different
ratios with a wild-type DNA that does
not include those variants and then what
you're hoping to see there in the figure
at the bottom is a nice linear
correlation between the observed allele
frequency on the y-axis and the
theoretical allele frequency based on
your mixture experiment on the x-axis
and so in this case you know you'll
often see two populations the ones that
are you know approximately linear linear
at about y equals x are your homozygous
various and then sort of I have variants
e set up as an example of what a
heterozygous variant might look like
we're even at one hundred percent cell
line DNA it's really only getting up to
about an allele frequency of 0.5 these
are all hypothetical data just to give
you an idea of what it would look like
real world data can look quite different
and will vary significantly based on the
variant itself so some variants you'll
have much higher sensitivity variants
that are difficult for the essay to
amplify may show unusually low accuracy
or sorry unusually low sensitivity and
so what many research
will do is they will number one average
all of their test variants together to
get an overall limit of detection or
sensitivity figure for the assay and
then also if there are key variants like
you really want to be able to look at
egfr or you really want to be able to
look at a particular care as variant you
may calculate a specific limit of
detection for those variants as to make
sure that the essay is capable of giving
you the key data that you're looking for
and then finally I wanted to mention how
important it is to always validate assay
performance with matched sample material
if you know that your clinical essay
will be done on ffpe tissue or you know
cell-free plasma-derived DNA be sure not
to validate your essay exclusively using
cell line DNA on you can source clinical
or commercially available samples that
are the same type mr. clinical material
to be tested and you're going to ensure
that the assay still meets all of those
data quality standards established by
your validation experiments so some
limitations of ngf as a clinical assay
to start to wrap up so again NGS as you
probably noticed it does require
significant setup costs there is
specialized instrumentation particular
training staff require and you know the
the implementation of an analysis or
interpretation solution that allows the
already doing NGS is unlikely to have
access to also the majority of
technologies being applied to the
clinical environment are short read
technologies and those are not
particularly well-suited for identifying
large structural rearrangements or
insertions in the genome so for example
short tandem repeats common in sort of
forensic human identification tests
internal tandem repeats such as what's
found in the slippery gene you know
anything that changes the fragment size
of the of the amplicon is going to be
difficult
to assess with a short read technology
another concern is that many common
clinical sample types can be difficult
to work with for NGS so for example
fixed bone marrow aspirate cloth or
anything that has a very high
cross-linked protein content can be
difficult to extract DNA and RNA from
and as well as samples where it's
difficult to get a particularly pure
tumor glass bead so a very high
percentage of the sample containing the
normal genome of the patient will reduce
your sensitivity to detect tumor
variants and another thing is that
negative results which is essentially to
say no variant or Association sounds can
be difficult to interpret it's up to
tell whether there's really no variant
present or if the athlete sensitivity
was just not sufficient to detect it if
the variant was present in the patient
but maybe not in the sample that was
obtained or in the case of disease
progression was the sample too old to be
relevant to the current clinical
situation and then finally the clinical
patient outcomes information necessary
to interpret the data and the
significance of the results can
sometimes be harder to obtain them the
NGS data you know we can create
standards for the quality of the NGS
data but in many cases there are not
standards for the ways that physicians
are recording on patients phenotype or
outcomes or the way that a patient is
presenting and so this connection make
it significantly harder to do any sort
of statistical analysis that leads to
clear conclusions from an NGS experiment
so just so just a few take-home messages
then now that we've sort of covered the
intro we've talked about getting started
with NGS and we've walked through a few
examples of some validation experiments
you know so NGS basically comprises
multiple new technologies that allow the
rapid sequencing of much larger amounts
of genomic information than most other
standard clinical at phase at the same
time reliable and accurate NGS is
definitely
accelerating the development of
personalized or precision medicine and
has particularly valuable applications
and inherited disease and oncology but
we should keep in mind that not all NGS
data is created equal you know assay
data and service provider labs should be
held to strict quality standards and all
ng FFA is used in the clinic should be
fully validated according to CLIA
guideline and the final thing is just to
carefully consider the question being
asked ensure that the samples that
you're able to collect in a clinical
environment have the power to answer the
question being asked before beginning
and NGS based study okay and just in
conclusion you know I'd like to say that
NGS technology is clearly integral to
the future of personalized medicine and
whatever regulatory approach is
eventually adopted and the types of
assays would start to be become routine
in the clinic I think we'll all expect
to see a great deal of continued
innovation in the field as technologies
and aphek developments contribute to the
advancement of medical care and with
that I'll just say that quick plug for
current portfolio of NGS samples inside
solutions so we certainly are interested
in partnering with researchers who are
starting to implement some of these
technological methods we have a full
portfolio of products available from
nucleic acids isolation through NGS
library prep as well as sequencing
analysis and interpretation and we
encourage you to kind of check out our
portfolio and see what we have to offer
your research and with that I'd like to
thank you for listening and take any
questions Thank You Jennifer for that
informative presentations it is time for
Q&A if you have a question would like to
ask Jennifer please do so now click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click send we'll answer
as many of your questions as we can and
we do have a question already in our two
audience member asks what is the
difference between hybrid capture and
click on sequencing why might you choose
one over the other the great question if
I can go back and I will show this slide
really quickly so hyper capture and
amplicon based data are two different
ways to reduce the region of interest
and sort of tailor your essay to adjust
the sequences that you're interested in
interpreting the difference is that in
amplicon data generation you're using
PCR primers to only amplify up the
sequences of interest in a hybrid
capture experiment you're actually using
probes so nucleic acid probes that are
complementary to the sequences of
interest and doing like a pull-down
experiment where you are capturing just
the sequences you want to analyze
through NGS and washing away and
disposing of the rest of the genome and
so the the reasons what you might do one
of the other amplicon has an upper limit
on how many different targets you can
realistically amplify in the same tube
and so if you want more than about 100
kb or 200 kb worth of genomic regions
and you to be included in your essay
you're more likely to go with a hybrid
capture method likewise if you want
something that is going to facilitate
easy analysis and straightforward
interpretation sometimes amplicon based
methods can be a little bit easier to
work with and they're also easier to use
with very small amounts of inputs ena
which is a common problem in clinical
sequencing great thank you we do have
another question how can the kaijin gene
reader instruments be used in clinical
sequencing so the courage and gene
reader was just announced last week at
the amp conference in Texas and the
generator is a little bit different from
other NGS technologies on the market in
that car is marketing sort of an end to
end product so instead of there being a
library prep kit and a sequencer and
analysis software the gene reader NGS
system is kind of all of those things
all in one with the goal of providing
actionable results are actionable
insights that clinical researchers can
use as opposed to requiring you know the
piecemeal assembly of a workflow and
figuring out which products to match
with which the junior system i think is
really different from other NGS
technologies in that it is targeted
towards a clinical environment
specifically thank you for that I think
we have time for one more question we do
have it in here and a cube audience
member asks I am seeing kaya seek
effects here in the NGS workflow what is
that so C going back to the portfolio
slides so you can see under our survival
workflow at the top where it starts from
the sample goes through nucleic acid in
isolation library preparation and QC and
then sequencing and analysis chiastic
effects is sort of there at the top I
think that's what they're asking about
this is a new library technology that
cotton has just launched specifically
for whole genome sequencing and hybrid
capture technologies and so what this is
is an enzymatic fragmentation technology
that generates those short read
technology capable fragments that you
can then either just sequence all of
them and do a whole genome essay or you
can use hybrid capture based targeted
resequencing to reduce that genomic
complexity to a region of interest and
then sequence that so coyote effects is
our first library kit that incorporates
the sort of enzymatic shearing workflow
and our performance data shows that it's
quite comparable to Cabarrus which is
another technology that many labs views
but you have the benefit of it all sort
of being able to be done in a standard
thermocycler great thanks for that
answer your questions but I just like to
ask Jennifer for sale for any last
comments or advice for our audience
members I think I've provides all the
advice that I have for today but you
know thanks to all of the attendees for
listening in and I hope this has been
useful Thank You Jennifer again for
being
of this virtual event I'd also like to
thank our sponsor kyochon for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing truth may of 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available to replay and we would
invite you to share that announcement
with your colleagues may have missed
today's live event that's all we have
for now thank you for joining us